[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar del auge de la extrema
derecha en Europa y cómo ha cambiado la
estrategia la estrategia dentro de los
países de la Unión Europea para ello la
vamos a melium Ortiz periodista
especializado en el estudio de populismo
y discursos eurocépticos o con maestría
en la Unión Europea Emilio Buen día
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana jueves en directo América de
Francia 24 también nos acompaña en
nuestra mesa de trabajo en nuestra
periodista Marta Moya Marta Buenos días
Emilio qué tal quería
empezar esta estas preguntas
diciendo un poco cuál puede ser el punto
de inflexión en el seno de los partidos
euroestépticos en este cambio de
posiciones
de los de los partidos de ultraderecha
no porque veíamos a melón y que decía
que tenemos que establecer el debate de
la soberanía sin plantear que nos vamos
de la Unión Europea cuál puede ser este
punto de inflexión que marca el cambio
de discurso
Bueno yo creo que es muy claro no el
punto y el punto es el brexit el hecho
de que al Reino Unido la salida de la
Unión Europea le saliese mal o le esté
saliendo mal porque en el presente
también se están viendo las
consecuencias ha provocado que quienes
hacían digamos seguidismo de esa idea de
del éxito no de la coletilla de éxito
ahora ya se lo piensen dos veces y de
hecho salvo algún detalle por el estilo
que pueda mantener alternativa por
Alemania el resto de partidos
eurocépticos ya no están en esa idea
esto podría ser Emilio digamos hacer
tambalear a la Unión Europea digamos que
más países estén con la idea de salirse
de este bloque o también como lo
estábamos hablando hay un cambio en los
partidos de ultraderecha de mejor
reformar reunión europea desde adentro
digamos para que los países tengan más
autonomía y no sea formato como un
bloque
Sí de hecho es para la Unión Europea
como tal es más peligroso lo segundo
porque al final con lo primero digamos
que el país que se sale o o los países
que se salen se aíslan que es lo que
está pasando con el Reino Unido pero si
dentro de la unión se forma un bloque
fuerte que Apuesta por una
desintegración de del proyecto europeo
es decir quitar competencias a Bruselas
para que las recuperen por así decir los
estados miembros eso sí que genera
una fricción muy difícil de corregir
para la unión yo te quería preguntar
Emilio la guerra en Ucrania y esta
crisis inflacionaria Por una parte deja
a una Unión Europea fuerte que toma
decisiones que se pone de acuerdo que
impulsan medidas de calado contra el
régimen de Putin pero también las
consecuencias derivadas de esta guerra
pueden traer consigo debates también
ultranacionalistas a corto y medio plazo
Hasta qué punto es viable no que se den
estos debates que esta Unión de Naciones
que plantean los partidos de
ultraderecha prospere
a ver realmente ahora las formaciones
eurocépticas no tienen una mayoría en
los gobiernos nacionales como para
decidir una reforma de los tratados que
quite competencias a la Unión Europea Es
verdad que estamos viendo una tendencia
de auge no de partidos eurocépticos lo
hemos visto con el nivel de voto de
Marín le pen en Francia pero más
recientemente tanto en Suecia como como
en Italia con Georgia meloni Pero
todavía es pronto para hacer un análisis
tan tan a lo grande no de una reforma de
la Unión Europea y es que la sensación
que da Después de la pandemia y ahora
con la guerra es que el camino es el
contrario el camino es hacia una mayor
integración de la Unión Europea lo vimos
con las vacunas de la covid lo vimos con
el fondo de recuperación lo estamos
viendo con el envío de armas a Ucrania
chocan dos modelos no yo creo que
estamos más cerca de una apuesta la
integración que de una apuesta por la
desintegración eso no quiere decir que
no exista un auge de los partidos de de
ultraderecha que por cierto ahora mismo
están en su máximo de votos en la Unión
Europea por ejemplo ungría y Polonia que
están en el seno de la unión y que
tienen gobiernos reaccionarios con esta
integración europea pueden servir de
ejemplo para estos partidos de
ultraderecha que aspiran a estar en los
gobiernos a corto medio plazo
Sí de hecho son El ejemplo
especialmente hay un hay una comparación
muy sencilla en el caso de Italia con
con el caso polaco por qué porque al
final el gobierno polaco de dni y
Justicia es un gobierno eurocéptico pero
al mismo tiempo es atlantista Es decir
es brotan No tiene un peaje que pagar en
el sentido de
estar cerca de Moscú o servir de apoyo a
Putin cosa que si le pasa si le pasa un
griega Entonces el modelo polaco al
final te deja como duro escéptico en una
posición ventajosa Por qué Porque de un
lado apoyas a Ucrania y de otro estás
más por la por la alianza de Naciones no
que es como lo quieren llamarlos los los
líderes eurocépticos Emilio a fin de
cuentas a los gobiernos Entonces les
conviene más estar dentro de la Unión
Europea que fuera de ella
Sí yo yo A las pruebas me remito Yo creo
que con lo que estamos viendo con lo que
hemos visto en el Reino Unido queda muy
claro que que la apuesta de los de los
partidos eurocépticos debe ser Sí si
tienen fuerza suficiente una reforma de
la Unión Europea desde dentro antes que
salirse es salir salirse hay una frase
que se repite mucho en en Bruselas que
es que fuera hace demasiado frío Bueno
pues el Reino Unido se está congelando
entonces el resto es lo suficientemente
inteligente está siendo lo
suficientemente hábil como para no jugar
esa baza de salir de la unión incluso
Emilio y Marta luego el brexit está este
distanciamiento de Escocia con el Reino
Unido ya están planteando otra vez hacer
un nuevo referendo porque ellos dicen
que se sienten más europeos O sea que
digamos seguir no siendo británico fuera
de la Unión Europea Marta tal cual yo te
quería preguntar Emilio en el seno de
los de los partidos de ultraderecha
tampoco hay un consenso claro sobre ir
Unidos en el parlamento europeo No de
hecho ahora mismo hay conservadores y
reformistas el partido donde están los
polacos de ley y Justicia con vox de
España esta identidad y democracia donde
está la liga de Mateo salvini con
agrupación Nacional de lepen y luego
está el fidettes de que está en los no
inscritos Esto puede cambiar de Cara a
las elecciones de 2024 puede haber una
Unión de partidos de ultraderecha para
hacer equipo para sumar fuerzas
a corto plazo es difícil es decir son
partidos que en su en su en su identidad
nacionalista
son poco dados a grandes acuerdos
Es verdad que es una de las grandes es
una de las grandes metas de la
ultraderecha europea al tener una gran
familia dentro del parlamento europeo
que si existiera
sería la tercera más potente incluso por
delante de los de los liberales pero a
corto plazo eso no parece viable y de
hecho los propios hermanos de Italia ya
la semana pasada dejaron claro que esa
no era una de sus prioridades y además
la frase que que se remarcó de aquellas
declaraciones fue que todavía hay
diferencias insalvables entre
conservadores y reformistas y e
identidad y democracia sí que podremos
ver
a Víctor orban y a fidez integrándose en
conservadores y reformistas ncr para no
quedarse Digamos como ese verso suelto
pero una una apuesta común de Cara 2024
a mí me parece todavía complicada
tenemos que ver también qué pasa no en
estos próximos meses en Ucrania y las
consecuencias de la guerra para
determinar un poco Hacia dónde se mueven
estos partidos todo está por verse Marta
y Emilio Gracias Emilio por estar con
nosotros estaba mañana el jueves en
directo América de Francia 24 estábamos
conversando con Emilio Ortiz periodista
especializado en estudios de populismos
y discursos de euro escépticos con
maestría en la Unión